Hey, what's up guys grant here hanging out with Chris Caron and listen
We're gonna be giving away this iPhone ten to one of you for our upcoming self-made event happening in April. That's right
We're gonna fly one of you down here all
Expenses paid to hang out with us for three days so we can train you on how to do YouTube just stick around
We'll show you how hey guys I'm Nate welcome back to the king of random today. We've got another experiment
We're gonna try because I think
Hundreds of people have requested to see this we're gonna see what happens if we take thermite and pit it against dry ice
The plan is pretty basic
And it's fairly similar to when we did our test with liquid aluminum and dry ice we've got a big old block of dry ice
We're gonna bore a whole part of the way down through the block
We're going to fill that hole with thermite, and then we're gonna light it off
We'll find out what will happen, which one do you think will win the thermite or the dry ice?
All right, there's a block of dry ice now let's fill this up with thermite powder
It's a good amount all right, we're gonna use a sparkler as a fuse and
I'm gonna put it in upside down just so that I can light the base of it and
Not have to you know deal with the wire on it
Here we go sparkler
Sort of the weirdest birthday cake I've ever seen
one heck of a candle and
The frosting is not that great there we go
Here we go
Whoo that whole block is glowy orange. Oh, and now we've got molten metal
Flowing around down inside that looks awesome. I'm hoping that the GoPro is picking up the glowing block
From the side because you can definitely see light
Coming through the side of the dry-ice just from the heat of that molten iron that looks really neat oh
I love that
beautiful
There's our little block of iron
at least part of its iron
Is this nice carved out hole into our dry ice?
knock off a little bit of the extra dirt and
Iron beads that have landed on here
Let's get more thermite fill it back up and light it off again
Okay, guys grant Chris jumping back in for just a second with a few more details about our event in April
And how you can spend three days with us all-expense-paid roundtrip two-hour self-made event that's right
We're flying you down to teach you everything we know about how to build a successful YouTube channel
Or you could win the iPhone 10, we're giving that away as well now this isn't gonna be for everyone
But there are two types of people out there
We want to talk to you specifically you're either trying to make a living as a youtuber and getting
Frustrated because the platform keeps changing and everyone who seems to be successful on YouTube
isn't answering your emails or you're a business owner who understands that YouTube is one of the Internet's best-kept secrets on how to create a
Perpetual lead base that can help your business grow and take it to a whole new level
But no one's opening up and showing you how to do it if you're not one of these two types of people then this event
In this contest is not for you, so don't worry about it, but if you are then here's the deal
There's a link in the description below where you can learn more about our
Self-made youtube trainings or enter our giveaways one of you is gonna get a free
all-expenses-paid round-trip ticket to the event
backstage pass VIP seating VIP dinner with me and Chris and what else happens
And staying in one of the nicest rooms in the hotel
We're putting you up in a suite by the way the iPhone 10 is the best that you can get its
256 gigs this one has the gray body and we're sending it with the gift receipt this thing cost over
1200 bucks so if you want you can just take it back to Best Buy and get the money instead you could also subscribe to
our new
Self-made youtube channel where we're going to be giving away some of our very best tips for free the prizes are great
But the real win is all the information hands on experience you're gonna get at the event itself this is gonna
Save you years of failure and struggle on your journey to become a YouTube success
We're picking the winner in two weeks
So click the link below everyone who enters is gonna win some whether it's free tickets the event
Discounts the iPhone 10 or something else everyone who enters this giveaway is gonna win something so go make sure your name is on it
So click below get your name on the list and we will see you in April
All right
Pack it down in just a little bit. I'm not trying to make it too dense or anything. I just
Wanna really make sure a lot of its in there
Sparkler did a great job of igniting it before
Ah that looks so cool just a puddle of our molten iron inside the dryer
I love that glow through the side wall that I had
It's so cool
now I want to see if it's melted its way all the way through the block a
Little bit we just barely got through the bottom of it
Here's our reacted thermite
It's super super warm
Thermite versus dry ice which one do you think won?
I think they both did a pretty good job
The thermite melted this way down through the dry ice quite a bit, but with a single batch
The dry ice did still contain the thermite this stuff can suck a lot of heat out of something
Usually when we light off thermite
It just really sticks to the walls of everything that it touches, but because it can't stick to the dry
Ice this is kind of a first
Having this solid separate ingot as a result from our thermite pretty fun to look at I'm not sure what the difference is between this
blackened carbon bit and this shinier more metallic living spot
Kind of think that maybe this is some nice pure iron, and this is like some slag
But I could have that backwards or maybe the aluminum has separated itself out somehow
I need to do some tests that looked really cool
I loved the glowing molten metal inside the dry ice just glowing orange through the walls of it
I thought that was such a cool look
Really glad I did this. Thank you guys for recommending
This as I said we had
tons of people who wanted to see thermite versus dry ice
If you've got an idea for a cool experiment you want to see us
Try let us know down in the comments we checked throw them and try and find all the good stuff
Hey guys quick reminder. There's a link down in the description right now where you could win this?
256 gig iPhone 10 or
all-expenses-paid round trip tickets to come join Chris and I at our
Self-made YouTube training in April or you could just click right down there hit the bomb if you're not already a subscriber
And we'll see it self-made